1 in 4 people have a hole in their heart.
59 of the 60 oldest living people are women.
A newborn blue whale puts on 14 stone every
day.
To sleep for one night in every bed in Las
Vegas would take 288 years.
A common form of public apology in Japan is
shaving one's head.
Full-fat or whole milk only contains 3.5%
fat.
The critically endangered Kakapo bird has
a strong, pleasant, musty odour which allows
predators to easily locate it.
Hence, it is critically endangered.
Two teaspoonfuls of Botox are enough to kill
everyone in Britain.
The hole in the ozone layer over Antarctica
is twice the size of Europe.
Arnold Schwarzenegger earned more than £20,000
per word for his role in Terminator 2.
In spite of 'women and children first', men
are twice as likely as women to survive shipwrecks.
During 19th century construction of Paris's
underground sewers, workers found lost medieval
dungeons, jewels, and the skeleton of an orangutan
that had previously escaped from the zoo.
The richest 85 people in the world have as
much money as the poorest 3.5 billion.
The Dutch Crown jewels are made of fake pearls,
fish scales and coloured foil.
80% of Italians under 30 years old live with
their parents.
In 2013, a PayPal computer error briefly made
a man in Pennsylvania the richest person in
the world.